rápido Qué importancia ha tenido
Venezuela en este principio de acuerdo y
Qué importancia tiene que junto con
cubanor y Noruega sea uno de los países
garantes del proceso
es muy importante la participación de
Venezuela no solo en este momento sino
históricamente varios procesos de paz en
Colombia se han intentado liderar o más
bien tener el apoyo digamos desde
Venezuela Entonces en este momento es
vital hay dos clases de países hay unos
países garantes y unos países
observadores el garante es el que va a
dar la mesa temática la metodología y la
logística en el proceso de paz con las
Farc fue Noruega y Cuba y los países
observadores son países acompañante a
cada una de las delegaciones muy
seguramente Venezuela será el país
observador que Acompaña a la delegación
del Ln y el estado colombiano acogerá
otro país para que también lo acompañen
el proceso de paz fue chile pero aquí Lo
importante es que se ha avanzado y que
por primera vez después de más de cinco
años nuevamente vemos al equipo
negociador de un gobierno de Colombia ya
prestó para comenzar estos diálogos con
y precisamente Qué diferencias se puede
esperar en este proceso entre el Ln y el
gobierno Petro Respecto a los diálogos
con los gobiernos pre de Colombia como
el de Juan Manuel Santos o el de Iván
Duque
Bueno lo primero importante es que ya
hay una metodología que se avanzó en el
gobierno de Santos ya hay unos puntos
que se limitaron en el gobierno de
Santos y ya hay un camino que se ha
avanzado no vamos a arrancar de Cero y
eso va a ahorrar mucho tiempo en la
negociación lo segundo en el lln sabe
que es estratégico llegar a un acuerdo
En este gobierno Un gobierno de
izquierda que puede ser más fácil llegar
a lo que tenía en gobiernos anteriores o
más de 20 años que estuvo el uribismo en
el poder y lo tercero es que también ya
hay un espacio político que abrieron las
FARC que se que saben que pueden llegar
a ser política y que ya tienen como unas
lecciones aprendidas de lo que fue el
proceso de paz con las Farc entonces
tienen varios elementos varias certezas
y claridades que antes no existían y
precisamente hacía referencia al acuerdo
con las Farc en el caso del eln qué
líneas principales Podría tener un
eventual acuerdo
bueno tener temas estratégicos el tema
de víctimas y y todo digamos lo que es
la reparación integral a las víctimas y
la justicia transicional eso ya está hay
una estructura con las Farc que viene
funcionando que es la justicia especial
para la paz Entonces el lln sabe que se
va a [__] a un modelo un modelo que ya
está funcionando lo segundo el tema de
participación política las Far tiene
algunos reparos pero en términos
generales ellos han participado han ido
a candidaturas etcétera entonces el Ln
también se podría [__] a esto y lo
tercero en términos de implementación de
los acuerdos hay vacíos hay cosas por
mejorar pero ya hay un modelo que se ha
implementado entonces bajo esas tres
dinámicas el elen y ya se puede subir a
cosas ciertas ahora que va a ser nuevo
en esta negociación con el Ln primero
que le lee ni quiere que haya un
replanteamiento del modelo minero
energético en Colombia eso va a ser muy
difícil ha sido uno de los puntos de
quiebre lo segundo que haya una
participación masiva de la sociedad
colombiana eso tampoco ha sido claro
cómo va a ser y esos van a ser Digamos
como esos dos puntos difíciles de tratar
en una mesa de negociación